[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
some
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
me
[Music]
[Music]
go live so
let me let me make sure i i pause that
oh i accidentally brought up my discord
ain't that ain't that uh
that's unfortunate i'm at the stop i'm
about to turn that off
like because like discord just be
bugging sometimes like they'd be
they'd be blowing my stuff up man like i
can't get it to shut up unless i go in
there and physically
like mute servers but i'm in so many
servers
it's unreal appreciate everyone coming
through man this is the attic show where
we talk about the past future and
present of i
i missed up the order there the past
president future game
i'm here with randolph thor man the man
with the million
uh what what have you been doing ryan uh
you know i've been i've been playing
some games attic on the attic show the
first time
uh first time you've invited me to your
actually actually technically you've
been on another one
but oh have i it was a long time ago it
was i had an
attic show on halo wars once and that
was
years ago uh hey oh yeah yeah i actually
remember that
that was back in what 20 was that 2018
yeah what's funny is like i see a lot
more like
people doing like one-on-one stuff and i
think
i've been doing that for years it's just
i've never been consistent with it you
know what i'm saying like
addicts like i pioneered this i didn't
necessarily pioneered it but i was
definitely doing it like so
so i don't want to hear no people like
added copy of me nah
like i ain't gonna say you copying me
but we ain't saying i'm copying you
that's not gonna roll
but uh you know so so what games have
you been playing man uh well okay i
don't even know if you're under
any kind of uh indiana no no all the
ndas are
essentially up um i played the
psychonauts 2 preview which uh you know
i i actually quite enjoyed uh i'll be
talking about it more
on xbox 2 this friday um
but yeah the second s2 really surprised
me man i wasn't expecting much
you know what i mean it's been a long
time since i played psychonauts one
but i put about six hours into the
preview and uh i'm really looking
forward to
playing the final release uh in august
so
you know we can't let you just go right
by that man the xbox two what
when is that gonna be what what what
time man people gotta see that
the psychonauts greatness that you're
going to talk about greatness yeah you
know we do xbox 2 every well
you see the problem with xbox 2 and me
and jazz is you never know if it's going
to be a friday or a saturday show
so usually it's it's fridays around uh
3 p.m central time best time about you
know
4 p.m eastern i'm not going to go into
that because obviously we've had words
we'll just all agree that it's better
than western oh everything is always
better than west coast
west coast well actually i don't know
mountain time is pretty bad
too so i don't know like i've lived in
the west coast
um for for probably half my life
it's not too bad in certain aspects i do
like the west coast but there are
certain aspects that you just like
why you know what i'm saying like but i
i feel like
i do get a little bit of jealous when
there's like release dates
and they they get access to it like way
earlier than us you know what i'm saying
like
like it's not that they get access to
earlier than us but it's
i mean they get access at the same exact
time earlier in the day
yeah it's earlier for the day so like i
come home
from like working a 12-hour shift or
something i got to decide whether or not
that game's worth a little bit lack of
sleep the next day
they come home man it's just like a
regular day to them
you know what i'm saying like oh it's
it's it's what nine o'clock there
you know it was ten ten no nine yeah
nine but you know it is what it is man
uh you know i think we both been playing
uh um
a death's door how do you how do you
feel about that game
it's uh one of my favorite games of this
year honestly like i
enjoyed i think i beat it in like eight
hours i enjoyed every second
i think the game is charming i think the
game's a lot of fun i think the combat
is enjoyable um the music is phenomenal
like
the level design like the art style like
that i started up that game not knowing
what to expect like i
read some previews and people said the
game was good
but that game just grabbed a hold of me
from the first second
and i was just like this is something
special and i was reading about it and i
saw that it's like a two-person dev team
and when you see that you're like you
can't help but be impressed by like what
two people essentially made this game
but dude dad that store um i love it i
it's absolutely fantastic in the game
what i really absolutely adore about the
indie scene is when you see
developers of that lower caliber and i'm
not not necessarily saying like their
game's low caliber
like but the the scale of their game and
you see that like
a good example of like a success story
for them is like
the people that made among us like it
was a very emotional thing for them at
the video game was like they were crying
and everything because like
i couldn't even imagine that the mindset
to making a game and it does okay but it
doesn't really like you know catch on
with anything and then like two years
later
when you're low-key in the middle of
making a sequel
and then you like your game just starts
getting downloaded like in the millions
you know what i'm saying like
like i don't i couldn't imagine what
it's like to be an indie developer and
have your game take off
because i'm sure triple a developers
like we saw
coralie bar corey barloff where he
didn't necessarily know what the
response was gonna be
to uh god of war and you know he had a
very emotional time when he saw the
review
uh the review scores but imagine what
it's like an indie developer when like
you kind of like
not only are you going at it from you
know
not being a triple a developer but
you're going at it a lot of these people
going and it's like
this is everything i got you know what
i'm saying like i put a lot of time a
lot of money like
and a lot of these places they don't
have you know the the ea's
funding and the the microsoft's the the
sony so it's nice to see
a success story in terms of indies when
it does happen
yeah well you've been playing it too
right yeah i play i played about
two hours over two three hours and what
do you think
i i like it there are obviously some
things like um
i'm not particularly fond of some some
of the creatures and they're not bad
it's just i i felt like you know the i
saw some bats
and looks like they just colored them
different colors and just slightly
altered the design and i get that
not really going to get them too hard on
that because like i like the aesthetics
of the game
i i ain't go light the very beginning of
the game yes this if you consider this a
spoiler
it is what it is it's literally the very
very beginning of the game
did you notice that that bus wasn't on
anything
yeah yeah i did notice that i was where
was the bus coming from
where was the bus wasn't even on nothing
it was off the mat
like i mean the whole uh that whole crow
realm
is not even on structure it's just
floating in midair
yeah what's going on with that i guess
you do have a point there but you know
it's a good game i recommend everyone
it's in game pass so definitely if you
guys
don't know it's not in gameplay oh it's
not in game pass no it's a 20
game i think it's on sale for 16. i bet
you
smooth bought it i bet you 20 bucks kid
smooth bought it i didn't know i mean
that's that's the only way to get it
because it's not on gamepad
unfortunately it's not on game pass but
the game is definitely worth your money
like it's definitely worth the money
yeah go out there and spend that 20
dollars man you don't got to wait for
everything on game pass man you don't
get
microsoft rewards if you have to yeah go
go on being man go on big so
let's go ahead jump straight into the
show ryan we got
we got halo infinite okay here we go
we your franchise my franchise right so
you know we we're going into halo
infinite
and i feel like it's been an up and down
up and down up and down i feel like you
think it's been
up and down man let me speak let me get
these bars off man
i got to finish it i feel like it's not
so much down right now it's kind of in
the middle you know what i'm saying like
like i i ain't gonna lie a year for a
year
a year ago from now i had very little
faith in halo
like like i remember coming out there
saying
don't expect much like it because
it's just like it's just how i've been
seeing it going up all
about but it's just like i personally
feel like me i don't know about you
we'll get to you in one second
but i personally feel like the the way
that they showed the multiplayer gave
them a little bit
in terms of you know revile
it not revolve revision it gave it a
little bit of hope a little bit of surge
in the community
like how do you feel like right now halo
is standing in terms of a brand
right like today i think halo is
i think halo is um i think people are
excited again man
honestly i i think i think there was a
point where people were down on it
like significantly in you being one of
them oh yeah i was definitely actually
you should hear an addict he was so down
on
halo i made a few videos right that was
them yeah you did
but after the e3 showing after the
multiplayer reveal
after you know the graphical overhaul so
to speak
um sentiment really changed about halo
and now with them talking about
flighting and saying hey make sure
you're signed up because it's coming
makes
and they're always like i think um
i think like people are excited again
man
they're looking forward to it this isn't
like last year where
uh you know they show it off during e3
and memes are made about it right
and you're just sitting there like oh
man xbox they screwed up again
here's halo and it's oh no look what it
looks like and
right all this stuff and um
you're just like man i don't wanna is
three four three gonna screw it up again
you know
it was a bad time last year i made it
i made a video ran i got a lot of flack
for it it's called three four three
versus
uh not three 343 versus bungie and i
remember i got a lot of flack over this
video
because i was like look i was asking the
community i gave my opinions because i
do personally feel like 343's made the
maybe not the best halos but the most
consistent halos you know what i'm
saying it
and i felt like three four three in
terms of uh you know them because
i bungees made the most consistent halos
and three four three
i've just felt like it's always
one point that i feel like they should
have but they don't got it
and you know i have a lot of faith in
the multiplayer i don't
necessarily got faith in the single
player right now what do you feel about
the single player
the single players were most concerned
about
um i i have all the faith in the world
in 343 to make an excellent multiplayer
game and i think you do too
yeah because they did a fantastic job
halo 5. yeah
and judging from how you know infinite
looks multiplayer wise i think they're
going to nail it again
and with how little i would say how
little they've showed up the campaign
because we saw a nine-minute demo of it
last year
but there is this trepidation
that the camp like it's like okay after
five which the campaign wasn't very good
it's like
please nail both aspects of the game
right
and that's the big thing for me like i'm
i'm a huge master chief fan like i love
halo
and i love his story so i
i want even though i understand the
multiplayer is the bread runner
right it's where they're gonna make all
their money it's probably the most
important mode
uh you know for the success of the game
and longevity of the game
i just want there to be like single
player and the multi-player
have equal standing like they put like
they put the same amount of energy
and thought and love and compassion into
crafting
you know master chief's story to make it
stand tall
and to make it so you finish it and
you're like that was damn good
that is a halo campaign now i'm gonna go
play some multiplayer
instead of like man what a waste of time
that was you know what i mean
yeah i personally felt like in terms of
halo there's a very
probably the last story besides maybe
gears because i think you know i'm
talking about
in terms of multiplayer and single
player like microsoft
has a lot more in terms of keeping
people satisfied because
i would say the same thing with gears
people really care about the multiplayer
but people care about the single player
probably equally just as much and the
same thing with halo halo
is one of the last first person shooters
where they can't just
skip and and pull a call of duty and
pull a battlefield where they're like
we're not doing a single player we're
doing a multiplayer because
they would get destroyed for that so
they have to make sure
that both are maybe not equally as good
but they have to make
both hit differently
100 100 i think you're right i mean
could microsoft get away with the
multiplayer only halo
in this day and age no they could you
don't think they could no
and i think the reason they couldn't is
because you know call of duty
battlefield uh they've always relied on
different perspectives of the war it's
never been like
a face to call of duty you know what i'm
saying they've been people that stood
out
but there's halo is the face of halo
i mean master chief is the face of halo
so
you can't do something unless you tell
you cannot make another halo game
unless you have some form of story
orientated that's
revolved around the master chief because
in that case you know
i felt like halo 5 would have been fine
right well okay let me ask you a
question
with this being the platform right
they've talked about their desire to
have
infinite last 10 years right um
assuming we get like single-player dlc
do you think
within these next 10 years at 343 do you
think we see another halo game that's a
spin-off
that that isn't part of halo infinite
where it's like hey
here's another game we're doing it's a
spin-off it's
60 it's single player or whatever
do you see that happening from three
four three or is it literally just gonna
be
it's just halo infinite from for the
next 10 years baby single-player
multiplayer dlc
maps and all that stuff i could see them
doing a spin-off but it just depends on
i don't think 343 would do a spin-off
you know maybe
we would have like another you know not
necessarily halo wars scenario but
you want a halo wars 3 i would love a
halo wars 3 but i'm referring to what
the majority would want the majority
don't want that type of gameplay
so you know i've always felt like i've
been attacked by this and i think pretty
sure you've attacked me by this too
i've always felt like coalitions should
make a third person cover shooter
halo game that's taking place in the in
the halo universe it's like
you could have been locked you can be
like one of the old arbiters
like there's so many different stories
that they could roll with that and i
feel like you
you you you put the coalition scenario
in there
you you give them access don't let don't
try to limit any of the the gore that
that coalition does
and like let it be a cover shooter that
like imagine going around with like
the elites uh the the the energy sword
and then like you're see it's kind of
like the chainsaw you know what i'm
saying like
i've always felt like like coalition
could make
a fantastic cover shooter in terms of
halo
hmm yeah maybe they could maybe they
could i i
i'll be interested to see what 343 does
because they have like a thousand
employees or whatever number it is right
750
um and it's like you really need all
those people for
you know making maps and everything for
halo infinite multiplayer single-player
dlc
it almost kind of seems like they are
set up to be like okay once we have
everything rolling
we can kind of move on to another
project
but still keep like halo infinite
because like reason respawn
you know they they do apex legends right
but they also are doing star wars
jedi falling order right uh and they
even i think they they even talked about
another project so
like once you're rolling with that like
games as a service
thing and you have everything situated
maybe you can move off and start other
projects that you know
you can launch alongside right i would
like
if they would have made this halo
infinite not a games as a service and it
would just be a
solid good campaign with a solid
multiplayer
and then after that they just they just
in the halo franchise for like
no and the halo i said for like a decade
like for a decade yeah like a whole
generation because like to me
man like i think 343 loves halo
but i think if you put that effort that
they have into their own ip i think you
would get better fruit if that makes
sense to you right
and i'm not saying like get away with
halo at all do the spin-offs but like as
far as the master chief
the the the master chief story i think
that needs to
how do you end the master chief story
look i know a lot of people he didn't
know look there's only one way that
master chief story wouldn't you say he's
going to give his life to save you gotta
die
so we just could he just gonna he gonna
retire into the sunset is that what's
gonna happen
like he's gonna die similar to just how
noble six died like
like and that's just my opinion because
at the end of the day like
i don't realistically see them just
retiring master chief
like something drastic's got to kill him
and
if if he doesn't save himself for like
for like cortana or something like that
i could see you know someone big has to
kill him but at the end of the day
who would they give that responsibility
to like
like you can't just let anyone kill him
like
it's got to be someone that would make
sense well what about your boy who's the
leader of the banished
atriox atriox uh i mean is he alive is
he dead we don't know
right at this point i think he's dead i
don't know why but i think he's dead
like yeah there's a lot of scenarios
like why are we talking to his general
there's no reason to talk to his general
like if if atriax was in charge of that
annihilation maybe he just left his
general there but if you listen to how
he's referring to atrialx
it sounds like he's he's respecting his
legacy you know what i'm saying like
it doesn't sound like he's talking about
someone that's currently alive and
it is you know i thought would be cool
is if somehow because in halo wars 2 the
hive mind
they almost rebuilt um they almost
rebuilt the uh
uh what's the thing called again um um i
think hive mind
that's what it's called in it yeah the
grave mind the grave mind they almost
rebuilt one
uh but you know atriox's uh people
stopped it right
right when it happened so i thought it
would be cool is if
something goes down between halo
infinite uh halo wars 2 and halo
infinite
and atrialx's body ends up
somehow becoming the gray mind like he
ends up like
taking control over atriox and that's
what's going on and
and you know maybe he dies and the the
gray mind decides to put his mind in him
you know what i'm saying like
like because because atrox there's never
been a villain like atriox and i'm
willing to put money on that like not
not like everywhere but in halo and he's
been so dominant
that if if he's not in halo infinite
something serious must have killed him
yeah maybe maybe yeah i don't know it's
be interesting but
i just can't i can't picture in my head
right now
playing a halo and watching master chief
die that's a sad moment
so i don't i don't know i don't want
that to happen
i don't want to because that that scene
where master chief gives up his life has
to be done
so perfectly with so much emotion
do you trust anybody to do that right
my question to you is that they're able
to do it
it would it would be something because
like to me
the only way they can end halo for a
while like i think they would reboot it
years down the road maybe not
necessarily reboot the whole franchise
but at least
a new hero and like to me
something like halo 3 how like you think
halo like master chief died
and you know they do in his funeral it's
got to be something like that
but on another level at this point you
know what i'm saying like
it's gotta be one of those things where
it's like it's pending back
and it's just like you know he
sacrificed everything for humankind or
like i thought it would be crazy is if
cortana just loses it to the point where
you know cause obviously we think that
cortana has somehow
you know restructured herself or
something i don't know what's going on
with this new ai but
let's say that cortana re controls that
rick takes over that
and she's about to do something so
drastic
that the only thing master chief can do
to save the whole universe
is to sacrifice himself to do it now i
don't
like right now obviously that sounds
corny you know what i'm saying but
everything can sound a certain way until
it's done if it's done right
it can be done well and i feel like if
they're able to connect those dots well
enough
it would satisfy everyone it's just that
there's a couple things how he dies
it can't be it's got to be one of those
things like you know how like
in halo 5 he was going through those
those uh those
those reactors in the guardian or
whatever it was yeah it might have been
halo 4.
like it's got to be something like that
like half the game you know what i'm
saying like he
he he's in a scenario where he doesn't
think he's going to win
and like you just keep seeing damage
more and more damaging
and you see him falling apart on screen
you know what i'm saying
no i mean i guess that could work but
let's be let's be uh let's be 100 here
halo makes way too much money for
microsoft for them to
uh put it on ice for a decade
you know what i mean so even though you
know
i mean i guess it's possible halo
infinite
could end the chief story right if they
if they do dlc for single player they
could end chief story but the
multiplayer could keep
going forever yeah and i think that's
what they would make the most money off
is the multiplayer
games of the service you know i always
thought it would be the craziest
twist ran this is this is never
happening but i thought this would be
crazy it's like
in halo infinite you're chasing uh
you're chasing spartan you
and you you oh there's another spartan
alive it could be someone from
uh you know the um from halo wars 2 uh
the spirit of fire
you catch up to him and you find out
he's he's not on a
he's not a good spartan like and then
you find out that
it's noble six from reach and he was
he he was captured on the brink of death
by atriox
and he brainwashed him this whole time
and then like the whole game
is chasing noble six
like i mean yeah i i that would be uh
that would be definitely something
but uh obviously we we got we just got
to get through halo infinite first
yeah it's gotta come out it's gotta be
good i mean it's gotta be great
right um single player's gotta be fire
it's gotta be a great co-op campaign
with uh it's gotta be a complete story
too like i wanna
a complete beginning i don't think
you're going to get that like i think i
i think we'll get an end i just also i
think you'll get
segments of an end like i think right
now you're going to get the segment of
the banished you're going to get you
know
yeah i'd say they'll probably finish
like the banish thing but then
maybe in a couple years we get the uh
you know the next
campaign that features him going after
you know cortana
or something um but no i'm much more
excited for halo infinite than i was
a year ago a year ago i was like
i don't know attic uh the way the game
looked that it's supposed to come out
this holiday with the system
i think it's coming in real hot yeah and
what's funny is like i
said on multiple iops i was like i hope
you know
and i was thinking i was like microsoft
this is going to be a sacrificial land
like that i i kept thinking that i was
like i hope they don't do it
i was like i hope they delay like they
need to and i didn't think they were
going to rand
i thought that halo being with the
console to me felt like it might have
been more important to them than halo
being good
if that makes sense to you right and i'm
glad they delayed it they
they realized like look it might be
might be pretty rough for six months to
a year but it's better if this game goes
back in the oven
so when it does come out it's got legs
yeah and it was also
you know we were worried there for a bit
that maybe they'd launched multiplayer
first
campaign six months later but they
decided to uh
launch them both as a singular product
which is the right move
so yeah i mean you know what like old
xbox
would have launched halo infinite last
year they would have
they would have been like all right
whatever we need this game
uh we needed to come out we don't really
care we'll fix it
as it goes and it would have launched
and it would have you know reviewed
horribly
and you know they would have they would
have been on the their heels
making up like excuses for why they
released it and why they didn't delay it
but
you know we're in a different era now
we're in an era that like hey the
coalition
is taking some time away from gears
right like
they're the workhorse of uh of xbox
game studios i feel like you know they
carried the whole xbox one generation
i mean they basically did and now
they're like yeah you know we're gonna
take some time
you know maybe even do a new ip
beforehand small project
get used to unreal but like xbox last
gen they would have been like no
we need gear six three years after gears
five
because you know what i mean like there
is no oh we need extra time you know
ever wild right we heard recently that
it was rebooted
old xbox would have been like uh that
thing's coming out they're you know
you're canceled instead of like you know
taking it back the drawing board
so we're at a different time for xbox
mainly because like
you know there's there's a lot more
goodwill uh there's game pass there's
all these different studios with all
these different games which xbox didn't
have so it gives
teams more of a time to polish a product
and get everything done
instead of like reaching a you know we
need this game out right now
i think that's what it is the most like
look like especially now they have
bethesda
it's like when someone comes up there
especially the caliber of like haloed
something they're like
oh you need you need six months you need
a year it's like you know that that
might
cost us money but i don't think that
they've pushed these games out in the
past because it cost them money i don't
you know obviously that's something they
don't want to do i think they pushed
these games out
because they realistically needed them
in that holiday
and you know obviously the money means a
lot obviously no one wants to
run a company at a loss but at the end
of the day no one wants to put a brand
out there without
an eye without any kind of flagship
title to to sell in the pr
in the holiday so when you don't have
that game and
only games coming out is like halo 5 and
then they come up to their like look we
need six more months well
you're the only game we coming out this
holiday we can't afford that
so you you're gonna have to go in there
but now it's not like that they go up to
they're like
halo 5 only one we got well halo
infinite let's say
you know they need more time for an
expansion all right you know
we got a vowel coming out we got fable
coming out like
you know we might go a month an extra
month without something
and then i've always said and i think
it's fair to say uh
rand that once they get this engine go
up and running
i've always felt like they're gonna have
to push push stuff back intentionally
because they don't want it too close to
other titles like for instance let's say
that
you know because i've been told the
outer worlds 2 is actually a little bit
more development than people think
and you know they actually people think
that's going to come out in like 2024.
i've been told that's that's not the
case like it it it's
it's it's supposed to be like the end of
2023 so they're launching a vowed
and out of worlds too at the end of the
day
it might get pushed back to the
beginning of 2024
but i think a lot of people are just
assuming it's like the end of 2024
beginning of 2025
and it doesn't look like that's the case
now let's say that
that doesn't happen then where's fable
where's perfect dart you know what i'm
saying like we're around that area where
these games are supposed to coming out
are they just going to start launching
one a month like i don't think they're
going to do that let's say
i mean we always be talking about the
old stuff i mean the new stuff the
the the new studios they bought bethesda
we're not even talking about none of
their
games like what happens when they're
like yo gear six is done
well we got like three games coming out
in the holiday like
we're gonna have to push that to like
march like
yeah i mean you know i also think it's
gonna be important for xbox to uh
one of the things i've always had a
problem with with xbox's releases addict
is they always back load everything to
the holidays they do i don't
i think the the amount of students they
have now i think we might see a little
bit less
with game pass you need to have stuff
at the beginning of the year and in
middle like you need to have something
in february or march you need to have
something
in you know may or june this isn't like
you
it's i don't think it's it's
you can hold everything to just the last
three months of the year anymore
you can like you constantly need stuff
so if like sure like you talk about like
outer worlds too
maybe it's end of 2023 but it might be
just best for microsoft to be like
no no let's just delay it a couple
months and have it come out in february
of 2024 so we got a game at the
beginning of the year you know what i
mean
and then and then what's crazy is like
we're not even talking about bethesda by
then arcane's probably gonna be ready
back
up because they're a well-oiled machine
like that
they probably already have an idea of
what they want to do next let's say they
go back they revisit dishonored like
like by then they're probably going to
be ready to go is are they going to
start launching that
are they going to launch multiple games
in the same month like like sure they
have what
um twenties how many teams they got
these days
uh well i mean they have 23 studios but
they have no way
over like 35 teams i think for something
like that yeah and you
they got that many teams and you know oh
no all of them are making triple-a
kind of products and no i don't think
making smaller ones yeah and i don't
think anyone expects them to make that
kind of thing but let me get this super
chat real quick
we got a 25 super chat from optimus code
gaming from the inside out that is a
weird name optimus car i'm not the
i'm about to give you that one man is
that the optimism that's the optimus
code
the optimus code man this dude look man
for anyone in this chat that don't like
optimus code that's not optimus code
i'm gonna call him out right now that is
a persona that he puts on
you know the persona from persona like
that's him like he got the mask on like
he'd be jumping in these twitter streets
and he'd be robbing people of their
emotions like
if you see something optimus code pose
that
you don't like just scroll down i
guarantee you
comedy on it obs like commenting on it
like
quote tweeting it you're just feeding
him just
scroll down what's his comment what what
said
what i was about to say uh he said mad
respect to gaming at it for being
consistent and keeping it a hundred
respect got respect to ran too
good stuff so far y'all don't mess it up
and it's like i said
optimus code's a good dude he just
sometimes i feel like he going a little
too much sometimes you just go a little
too
no not a little bit you go a lot too
much sometimes doctors come like
but it is what it is man i've always
felt the need when it comes to like the
trolling stuff i don't like it it's not
for me but
i ain't gonna tell somebody else they
can't troll people i'm just not gonna be
uh participating in that but we're gonna
we're gonna move on with that man you
know
uh you know let's just brief thing real
quick
what is your expectations personally for
halo infinite this holiday
um like what are you looking for a
metacritic score
yeah we'll give a metacritic score too
metacritic score and how you think it's
generally going to be perceived by
everyone
regardless the metacritic score well i
think
i think it's going to be received well
like i'm thinking
if i had a guess right now 86 87 88
like right around riding around in that
range i don't think it'll get in the 90s
i also don't think it's going to be low
80s i think they're going to absolutely
nail the multiplayer
um but i guess how high it's going to be
rated is going to depend on how
awesome the campaign is or how not
awesome the campaign is right
a lot of people a lot of reviewers want
the story they want to connect with the
chief
and i have a feeling a lot of reviewers
aren't going to even play the
multiplayer like that like
yeah they're going to play that single
player they're going to open up the
servers they're going to play that for a
little bit
and then you know that's as far as that
goes since the last time
a halo game came out in 2015 reviews has
sort of changed
a lot of outlets now will do review and
pop progress right
nobody was doing review and progresses
back in 2015.
uh a lot of outlets even do uh multiple
rev
like they'll do a review for the
campaign separately and then a review
for the multiplayer
separately and then like an overall
review
so it that's changed since 2015. i i
think a lot of people
honestly miss halo i think the five-year
gap has actually um
has kind of given people a a a time
to miss master chief and that's kind of
what i always thought was sort of
what they needed to do with gears
because gears has been releasing like
every three years
like they give you no time to miss
anybody on sarah or any of the
characters because it's constant it's
like
since 2006 when you think about it right
gears 1 2006 gears 2
2008 gears 3 2011.
here's judgment 2013 gears ultimate 2014
uh
gears uh was it 2014 for gears ultimate
yeah and then like 20
no 2015 for gears ultimate 2016 for
gears 4
2019 for gears 5 right and then gears
tactics 2020.
you know if xbox was following that path
we'd have a new we'd have gear six next
year
2022 right but they don't give you a
chance to miss anything
with the five year gap from from halo
like i think people
really do miss the franchise and i think
people miss
master chief so if 343 can come together
after the year delay
polish it up multiplayer's fire single
player is actually really good i think
you can
it'll be reflected in the reviews um
like i said i personally expect like an
86 to an 88
uh but you know it could climb into the
90s depending on how great the campaign
is i think
but you'll have to wait and see yeah
definitely so i put a poll in there in
that chat man what is halo infinite
score going to be
70s 80s or 90s feel free to go over
there and vote for that if you guys want
to
but you know i i what do you think attic
what do you think
86 because you because you're because
your thoughts have kind of
shifted immensely do you think it's an
a6
you think that's what's good 86 would be
a great score yeah i don't think it's
i i don't know see the wild card is that
that single player and
if that single player ends up being very
well done
and sure they they can leave certain
mysteries like where's cortana
i think this is how they're going to do
the single player i think they're going
to have a focus on this kind of like how
destiny does it but hopefully does it
better
and they're going to like this is what
we're doing for the for the vanilla
campaign of halo infinite
they're going to have a villain they're
going to have a beginning middle and in
it's just how well they do that
beginning middle and end and i think at
the end
after you've concluded that version of
the story
what's going to happen is they're going
to have like some in game cut scene
that's going to introduce what the next
story is going to be
and it will probably launch a couple
months later you know what i'm saying
so you know i hope it man because
besides
fable this franchise means a lot to me
and
i just don't want them to mess up man i
i feel like
and i feel like 343 they could use the
parade
when do you um when do you think it's
coming out you know we don't know they
say holiday 2021.
if you gotta put on if you had a bet
right now when you think it's releasing
or do you think it's getting delayed to
next year
i don't think he's getting delayed i
used to be on that but i've been told
multiple times that i need to calm the
[ __ ]
i need to calm down i can't cuss you
can't you can't swear on here man it's
your own show and you're not allowed to
swear
yeah it is what it is so i think that
september early october see i was riding
the september train too because i
thought it made too much sense like you
have battlefield in october and halo
and and uh call of duty in november and
i was like oh man september would be
such a great spot there's like really
nothing coming out that month
but i don't know the more i think about
it with the way they talk holiday 2021
and the fact that they haven't started
flighting yet right and i think
i think flighting is going to start in
august i'm pretty sure
i mean i'm not 100 but i feel confident
that the flighting is going to start
next month i think if you started
flighting in august and released in
september
it probably i i don't think i i just
don't see that
so i think what's happening right now is
they don't know when call of duty is
hidden
yeah and and halo
is in that position where they're like
okay we need to be a good platform for
our third parties
it's obviously not good enough not great
to launch halo and cod the same week or
even the week after each other
and we need to make sure that 343 is all
the time in the world we don't want to
stick to a date
so i'm starting to think holiday 2021
means
end of end of end of november or early
december
is what i'm thinking i cuz i used to be
on the
uh the train there's no way microsoft
doesn't know
third party release dates and what i was
told is
they know but they don't know like
they know outdated information but the
problem is it could change at any time
so they never make any kind of
decisions based on what they don't know
a hundred percent of you know what i'm
saying like
they don't want to come out there and
it's just like you know
it's just like phil spencer said i don't
want to delay this game even a week
like i won but he did say there was a
three to four week window that they know
when the game's coming
and you said october but october's
two-pack like october's got
far cry which they're co-marketing right
they have back for blood which is in
game past day one the next week
they got battlefield 2042 which they're
co-marketing
like there's no spot for them to launch
it in october
right so no end of like november
the problem is forza horizon is also
early november
and then hey you would imagine call of
duty's like the 15th so i don't know
like
i'm thinking like halos like end of
november maybe the week of black friday
that would be cool you know some like
around that time and if they absolutely
need it
you know they could delay it to like
early december so you know
optimus code again said uh he's got ten
dollars to present can you
please give your personal review scores
for the halo infinite campaign and your
separate review card for the multiplayer
i'd appreciate
it uh do you want to go or i'll go first
what do i think the multiplayer is going
to get yeah
if you think the multiplayer is going to
get a nine i think the multiplayer is
going to be really good
um even if i do wish it has a uh had a
battle royale mode
the single player oh i don't know i
think the single player is probably
gonna be
like seven and a half eight i don't know
i just expect the multiplayer to be the
more
complete um
part of the package i mean i don't know
from the stuff i've heard
the campaign was the one of the things
that was kind of the hold up
multiplayer is kind of the one that's
always
sort of been ready or close enough right
so i actually have a conspiracy if like
this gets pushed back i think that
the way they would do it is they would
make like a three or four month
probably three months a three month um
a three month beta for the multiplayer
and then ironically when the single
player drops
uh it's going to be both of them
dropping but it's technically being beta
the it's going to be delay it's the beta
is going to run the
the beta is going to run up to like a
week or two before the game comes out
and i and i think they would get flat
but i think that's the best
solution they would have if they did
need to delay this game
maybe yeah i mean we'll have to see i i
got faith that you know
the the what i've been told is it it's
it's
it's coming out this year we'll just
have to see but let's talk about
xbox old titles and
whether or not you feel like they need
to be rehashed obviously me and
uh you know code eastwood we go at it
over and over again about whether or not
banjo kazooie needs to come back
let me go ahead and read the super chat
real quick we got a two dollar strip
chat from king
uh perel i butchered it we're gonna move
past that will microsoft fix the
features with the share button
they've been saying that for a minute i
don't think they are i think they might
get to it eventually but i think that's
not
nowhere near their priority
uh but yeah and you know rand said no
too no i don't think that
i think what you have now is what you
get yeah
and it's just like to me when it comes
to the older stuff i feel like they have
such a variety of old titles
and you i want one game
if you had the choice phil's pitcher
came down he sat beside she's like
randolph thor
what did he do today by the way okay
we're gonna act like that didn't happen
you know you wanna know what i said to
phil back in 2015 what did you say
when we when i met when i met him for
the first time he asked me
what game out of everything all the
games that they could do what game would
i
greenlit like if i had my choice and you
know what i told him
he's like you can use anything and i'm
like
and you're gonna laugh because well
maybe not but like i said
phil i need alan wake too
and that was at the time microsoft still
had like the the publishing rights for
alan lake
yeah like i need you to go make a new
allen wake game with remedy
uh that was that was what i said i know
they don't i know microsoft doesn't own
the ip
um but if we're talking about ones that
only i p i
honestly like i'm not that big of a i'm
not
i'm not that big of like a one of those
people that is like constantly like oh
we have all these great old
uh x you know microsoft ips like
fusion frenzy and shadow run and all
this stuff
and project gotham racing like i would
probably say i really like project
gotham racing but there's no need for it
considering we have forza ryzen
so i'm just gonna go the tried and true
because i actually liked it
i want another killer instinct game
killer instinct
i want another killer instinct because i
really did like it but other than that
maybe another viva pinata because i
actually did
enjoy people pinata but
i don't really have a strong attachment
to a lot of the my
older microsoft ips that everybody seems
to have like you
really want of new banjo kazooie not
only you but like
everybody seems bring banjo back
i'm conquer back or some of the older
rare ips you know
i don't really care about conquer i've
never really cared about conqueror i do
i do care about uh fusion frenzy i think
you know not necessarily that microsoft
needs a party game i think it would be
very beneficial to them especially
something like game pass like you have a
games as a service party game that that
screams game pass
like you know you you kind of like how
fall guys does it to where like you
update the costumes like
i feel like scenarios like that could
really
give people reason to subscribe to
gamepad it's not just for that people
will subscribe to game pass for a
variety of different reasons not one or
the other
but i do feel like you know you get some
good courses in there
you really put money behind it because
that's the only way you're going to get
a quality one
and then i honestly feel like that would
be a huge hit
you know they they can do something that
mario party can't do
for up to right now because i know
they're about to have the first mario
party really have like a lot of online
features
and like to me if you come out there and
you have a lot of good online features
and you do what you know nintendo
refuses to do
you can captivate that audience
especially have an x
cloud where you have access to uh you
know more areas
you have game pass you have xbox series
s and x you have
the cheaper way of getting into the
french into the ecosystem with game pass
you that fusion frenzy a good fusion
frenzy i'm not talking about
one that they just they hand to anyone
and say make it a good
fusion frenzy i feel like would be one
of the biggest success rates they could
possibly have
um who okay who do you would make that
game
i have no idea an internal studio
it would be an external it would i don't
think
i couldn't tell like obviously i don't
know let's point out right now
these studios they can make pretty much
anything they want to appoint
as long as they hire some external help
to push the studio in the direction they
need to go
because a lot of these developers have
worked on multiple type of games but
i would personally want a studio that
focuses on stuff like this um there's a
game on pcs called like plummetal
hold up you're probably going to see my
steam stuff pop up on the screen
i apologize for that because i want to
see what this game's called
because this studio oh it didn't pop up
on the screen that's cool
this studio they make uh
it's a it starts with a p plumb a party
it's this game right here i'll put it up
on the screen
and i feel like this game
is definitely you know it's kind of like
what i would like
for them to do but you could tell it's
it's a very low budgeted one
and i feel like that developer they
could probably take that concept
if microsoft would feed them the correct
amount of money and the
flow and some new talent and make
something worthwhile
uh as much as everyone hates
banjo-kazooie ran
i honestly feel like banjo-kazooie is
their ratchet and clank if they actually
spend the money
in the in the time to do it who would do
it i
i don't know i feel like everyone at
rare
there's no way no one wants to make a
banjo-kazooie the higher-ups that rare
don't want to make a badger kazooie
i feel like there's plenty of people
that
are thriving for their own project
that's up there
in the ranks that haven't gotten that
opportunity yet like
give one of them it takes some people
like you know get a team of
20 30 40 people and go make
banjo-kazooie yeah
i don't know i i get it but i'm just
like to me ran
there's no reason why we can't have a
banjo-kazooie there's just none
yeah you would think they would they
would have one in production by now like
they had the crossover with
with super smash right or smash brothers
phil's talked about family-friendly
content
but like really realistically when you
look at the games that they're building
and the games that they have announced
they're definitely not much that i would
call
friendly family-friendly friendly um
yeah it's just i don't know if like that
maybe
they have somebody working on it but
it's just not ready to show but out of
all the games
that they could do i i've always thought
banjo-kazooie is a slam dunk to come
back
you don't even have to make a new banjo
kazooie you could just remaster the
first one
like not remastered like remake the
first one build it in the correct
new engine you don't even have to like
build banjo-kazooie four
or three or whatever one well there does
people consider banjo nuts and bald
spangle three or is that
i don't think they technically is that
technically banjo three yes but i don't
think people consider a banjo
three i i and for the most part you know
i played a little bit of it not a whole
whole lot
but you know i didn't like it that much
uh you know i loved banjo-kazooie you
know what's funny
rand i know you're gonna you're gonna
give me a lot of [ __ ] for this next
sentence oh geez here we go
i have played badger kazooie like 15
times i've played banjo too
i've never beaten none of them jeez why
don't you beat them what's going on
well every time i get into it like
something comes up i remember i had it
for the 360.
i'm on like the fifth or sixth stage
right now uh
but like i guess when i get to the parts
of the game
that um because i'm in a graveyard stage
on banjo-kazooie
every time i get to parts of the game
that i've never done multiple multiple
times i always get like mad stuck like i
i don't know what it is i need to go
back and i need to actually sit down and
actually play it
but it i might stream that whole game
i i might stream that whole game because
i love it man i i enjoy it
maybe it's because it's a little
outdated not even much like
badger kazoo is kind of kind of um
evolved decently like it's aged okay
like it's not aged like horribly
but you know it it is what it is is
there any other game that you would see
come back you know what i do want to
come back
one versus 100. oh i saw someone
yeah or some variation of that that is
something i could get behind because i
really do like that but
like i said i'm not i don't really have
a lot of nostalgia for
the old microsoft and rare ips i want
killer instinct to come back i really do
think it deserves it
i'd be down for a one versus 100
multiplayer style game
um if i had it like project gotham
racing but we don't need it because
forza rising
uh i wanted microsoft to do alan week
two but
you know it seems like they're doing it
with epic so i'm gonna get what i want
anyways
right i would have said sunset overdrive
too but you know
well these aren't older games i guess
it's like they don't fall into that
category so
it would be killer instinct for me and
one versus 100.
killer instinct definitely is a
it's it's definitely a good thing and i
think i think
killing sick now there is a lot of rumor
going around that there they might be
looking into purchase um uh netherrealm
i don't know if that's true we don't
have to really go into that because we
butchered the [ __ ] out of that topic but
i've always felt like
with with sony buying evo
and it looks like they might be uh
searching for another studio that makes
those type of games
if microsoft don't buy netherrealm
they're never going to have
even remotely a chance to get into that
genre ever again
i would say if sony bought another realm
the fighting game genre and xbox is just
gone
so i always viewed netherrealm as more
of a defensive measure
like if they were for sale you would buy
them because
you can't let them go to sony
simply because then you would have no
fighting games
um and i don't know about you let me ask
you this
hypothetical situation okay completely
hypothetical
microsoft buys netherrealm buys the
mortal kombat ip
off of them right mortal kombat ip
one of the biggest ips in gaming right
do you then
turn to netherrealm at boone and say
you know we just spent all this money
for you we got you the mortal kombat ip
but uh can you make us a killer instinct
game
does that make no sense whatsoever
here's how i would do it um i feel like
kill it's kind of like the injustice
mortal kombat thing
the first thing i would do and i'm not a
fighter anyone in the chat
that does fighting stuff educate me i
don't know [ __ ] about this this genre
i would do a killer instinct versus
mortal kombat first
yeah you probably could do that yeah and
then you know you really build the brand
and
who knows microsoft you know since they
don't really have a whole lot
into the fighting thing maybe that's a
studio that you would want to re
really really invest into and have two
teams uh one making killer instinct and
one making uh mortal kombat
and then after they both make their
prospective games they both come
together and make a killer instinct
versus mortal kombat you know what i'm
saying
so you know i think that would be a lot
of money going out
but i do think that that would solve a
lot of the issues with fighters they
would literally own mortal kombat and
kill their instinct and
and what i've been told caroline thinks
one of the it was one of the most
popular
fighters when it was at its height so i
mean i don't know i don't
do fighters man i don't do that stuff
but you know i really feel like
um the the the studio just makes sense
microsoft you need a killer instinct
game you have too many people want to
play this damn game
i want k mega off my back
buy it let them make it man i'm sure
you've been
asked multiple times they are they gonna
do killer instinct man what are they
doing with mortal kombat i mean i mean
yeah and
we've always said exactly what phil said
even before like
they want to do one but they just don't
have anybody to make it
you know so i mean it's just the way it
is now
that maybe they mean like hey we haven't
seen the pitch we haven't liked all
these studios are just busy
and we don't have one internally but you
know maybe it's maybe one of them you
know tur like it's like hey
you know we got time what do you think
of this pitch and and and
you know maybe they like it but i don't
know like
i want it to come back i i i guess
there's probably a better realistic
chance of banjo coming back than maybe
killer instinct but who knows maybe
maybe neither of them come back
maybe maybe they don't delve back into
well they just delved back
into the thing for perfect dark didn't
they so
yeah um and i think perfect art
it's i i've been told it's a first
person isn't it
yeah it's first person yeah i was kind
of disappointed with that i felt like
that would have been a good third person
thing but
it wasn't the original games for first
person so i guess that would technically
make sense it was like first person and
then when you took cover it was third
i mean that might be the case too i
don't think we've really seen enough
gameplay to really justify that
i just felt like that there's a lot of
scenarios and a lot of things that
microsoft can do like the one versus 100
you know imagine you do like
session game nights where it's like all
about halo you know what i'm saying like
halo questions
or about all about microsoft first
person questions remember
the attempt the attempt that microsoft
made on the fan fest to have like a one
versus 100 scenario that completely
bombed and blew up in their face
the the what the what the the question
the the
the q a thing that that they did for
that fan fest
where people had to answer it in a
certain amount of time and then
yeah i loved it that was so fun like
but obviously you know um they they had
a third
party app do it and you know they
weren't prepared for the amount of
traffic they got so didn't
really done they did it since and i felt
like take that formula
make it into a game and put it on xbox
one versus 100.
yeah but you know hopefully we'll see i
do feel like microsoft is making a lot
of moves behind closed doors
but we don't know until we actually know
uh but you know
so out of all the games we said yours
100 is keller instinct that's who you
want right
yep yeah that'd be number one now yeah
so
the next topic ran i was told this will
never happen again
you know so xbox
got got a little w in forms of the uh
you know the
the npd's and for those of you that
don't know the mpd's
it is a uh you know pretty much
mexico canada in the united states all
of the cells combined that's what the
mpd's are
and we got a ten dollars superchat from
slo-mo backslap
i ain't even read this and i know it's
going to be on some dumb stuff because
he always coming at me but we're going
to read it and see
if i'm right although i didn't get into
this one back then okay so maybe it
wasn't i apologize love them i'm going
to continue reading
but what if they did this crimson skies
remake
as an expansion to microsoft flight
simulator
and then a stand-alone sequel to crimson
skies that would be interesting the
the people who uh asbo or whatever the
hell their name is
a sub um like i think that that's a very
solid stew they might buy
but i think they could that would be
interesting if they did that
like kind of like they just did put
crimson skies in game pass
so does that mean something maybe maybe
not you know people always like does it
mean something
um yeah i mean slumber's not the first
person to ask for a crimson skies
remake reboot it definitely would be
interesting in this day and age the
multiplayer for it back on the og
uh was was pretty damn good um
but you don't see those a lot of these
type uh crimson skies type games anymore
really it's just like
what is the only like flying game
outside of microsoft flight sim that is
any sort of like
action is like what the ace combat
series i think
there's not that many of them there
really isn't and if you think about it
like microsoft could really lock that
genre down like
i've always stated look playstation has
the better games quality wise
there's no denying that i think that
you'll start to see that that scale come
a little bit
more center uh maybe not necessarily in
the the pure quality but i think
microsoft might have
more really good games than sony has
quality quality games does that make
sense to you
uh so i i think that might scale it out
a little bit but
you know as far as when it comes to
stuff like that i just
all that we can ask for is they just
spend their money
wisely because i feel like microsoft
they're throwing a lot of money out
there but
we've seen it ran throughout the years
sooner or later they're going to want
this money back
like and i don't want them making the
whole
so astronomic that it's impossible to
realistically get the quotas that they
need
but obviously there's people at
microsoft that clearly see
we need to reinvest again because they
keep reinvesting
uh you know and i'm excited to see but
anyway
you don't you you derailed the podcast
just a little bit slow-mo but that was a
good conversation but
we're going back to the smoke xbox one
and npd and i think it was in the terms
of the cost amount maybe not necessarily
the yeah
dollar figures so i did the playstation
sell more or was that just the switch
that sold more
switch sold more sold more units but
xbox made the most money out of all of
them
they didn't give any type of
if xbox outsold playstation they didn't
give that knowledge right
um i don't
know but anyway king's a big thing right
now is it doesn't matter how much you
push it out if we make
more money we win it like i don't know
if you saw last iowa people
of course iops ilps one of the mainstays
one of the first podcasts i listen to
every single week
you know i just gotta wait for them uh
from those time stamps oh i agree you
gotta
wanna listen to the king talk about
boxing and stuff you know what i mean
i'd be trying to tell them look man i i
you're preaching to the choir
i have went to bat with these people
over the sports talk
but every single time they got good good
good comebacks i can't really fight it
like i can't realistically
you know it would be different if it was
like 30 40 minutes but most of the time
keep me talking for three four five
minutes then it's over
like you know there's occasions where he
goes a little bit too
too extra and talk like 10-15 minutes
but for the most part king keeps it
keeps it simple keeps it straight and we
keep it moving
and you know i appreciate that because i
don't know
you've seen me every time combat talk
comes up
that's when i go get something to drink
or something to eat like
i just don't care about it it's like
it's not necessarily their fault it's
like when i talk about anime i'm sure
they don't care about that either
besides king king loves anime but
you know as far as what's going on with
npd's and i
don't want to necessarily center around
that they won the mpd's because it's
just one month i can't we can't see here
and act like
the tides changing you know what i'm
saying but it is interesting
that they won this particular month
because that's when ratchet and clank
was at its height wasn't it
yeah you know you could say uh
what look so both consoles had stocks
are going through stock shortages right
you can't really get an xbox can't
really get a playstation
but you are right though uh no
most people said this would never happen
you know once once the ps5 is going to
launch
xbox doesn't stand a chance uh it's
never going to beat it again and then
here comes month of june
um and it's sold more now i think
there's a couple reasons for it
microsoft timed a uh
great stock uh you know uh restock
to e3 right because remember right after
e3
there was a whole bunch of comments and
i do believe
the reception e3 had a lot to do with it
i think people
and i've even seen playstation guys
finally pick up an xbox
it was a good e3 it was a great it was a
great e3 you saw
a lot of mainstream coverage uh people
seemed really excited about
the future and they're like okay i'm
gonna get an xbox and there was
uh some available now you even factor in
you know uh
microsoft has been kind of shifting some
series x chips to put into x cloud so
those can run better
uh so they're not they're not putting
everything into uh
the channels and it's kind of funny
because you
because you mentioned you know xbox did
this or
even with playstation launching a big
exclusive of the year maybe their
biggest
not to mention you know return came out
like two months ago
a month and a half ago like yeah so it
is they're coming off a couple launches
it so it's interesting that
microsoft with no games and let's be
realistic they got games but they got
nothing from their first party yet and
they
doesn't say like xbox hasn't released a
game an exclusive game
i mean since the medium in january which
is now no longer exclusive or
gears tactics in november so they
haven't you know as people would say
xbox
you know had no games and they didn't
have any games in june
and it they won
so you know i think it just more speaks
to
um people's uh reactions to e3
and how good the future looks how
incredible game pass is
that a lot of people that were riding
the fence
uh decided to take the the plunge and i
think
i think you're gonna see um i think
there's a lot more interest in
xbox series than i than there ever
really was
for xbox one and i think it's gonna
continue
like not every month i'm not saying
they're gonna win every single month
but uh and they may never win another
month again
but um you know i think
i think xbox i think is going to do just
fine i don't i don't know
it's i don't think this is a fluke i
think they might not win next month but
i think that if anything it shows
they pretty much sell these consoles off
of game pass and i think that that's
what it is i think
um if we've known throughout the years
before game pass subscription services
in general came up
it was us selling these these games to
our friends in the party was it don
yeah let's play this man let's get this
sixty dollars oh sixty dollars
what's an easy thing would you yo let
let's play let's play um
uh what's a good game that's a
multiplayer game on i mean let's just
say gary is five someone just
randomly came into the ecosystem now i
don't want to pay for no game i just got
the console
you don't got to man get that game pass
like
and then when you're talking it like
imagine that's at a party right imagine
when you
when family members are talking to each
other like that that stuff
spreads and the crazy part is they're
doing this without
that that machine that they've been
building for the past couple years
imagine when that comes out obviously
these games got to come out be good
we can't say that they can go off
straight of game pass with no good games
but if we've seen just from them winning
this mpd
off of the height from e3 which was
pretty much dedicated to what
game pass i think it's safe to assume
assume that
when these games start coming out you're
gonna see this more often
yeah i mean you look at this holiday i
think if you have stock available
and you have you know the third parties
launching uh
but then you have forza coming out and
you have halo coming out
um i think people will want to take the
plunge
because they they they've seen the plan
they've seen the future they know what
game pass is they know
microsoft has all these games coming so
i think
it's just um i i don't know if it's
going to continue
every single month because honestly uh
playstation is
uh i think the more in-demand console
for sure
i mean clearly you know the case um
you know with with the stock shortages
happening it could
any month could be the month it's just a
matter of who
delivered more stock uh to the us
than the other one you know and think
about like this i i said this
i think in my video but it's harder for
microsoft to win
uh a dollar sales comparison because
they have a console at 500 and a
consulate 300
while playstation has at 500 and the
console at 400.
so the more series s's that microsoft
sells
puts them in a lower uh position to win
a dollar
sales uh sort of uh comparison because
you know the the series s is so cheap
and it's 100
cheaper than the digital yeah but i mean
we can be real i don't think that
even the digital ps5 i don't think
they're making a lot of those either
they're probably losing a ton of money
yeah so i think they're under print uh
they're
that's the one i own i bought that one
yeah
i got i bought mine off kid smooth it's
the uh it's a physical one
what's funny is he got a digital one off
bg and he was trying to
to get me to switch him and i was like
dude i'll switch you because i don't
care like i'll take the digital i was
like but you're paying the shipping for
both
like i'm not gonna no he was like he's
okay
i'm gonna do it because i guess he won't
he just wants the option for physical
you know what i'm saying
i don't care i don't i i haven't owned a
physical game since titanfall
so all my games on the xbox all my games
on playstation are 100 digital
physical is dead to me ew physical who
does physical anymore in this day and
age
plus you game share so you you basically
can get any new release for half price
and then sometimes you know i just i
just hold out and
kid smooth buys it first like seriously
like ratchet and clank came out
and it was my turn to buy the game so i
bought it right but it was 70.
but my buddy had bought returnal so like
i got
eternal and ratchet and clank for 70
bucks you know what i mean
so it's like why wouldn't you get
digital you know
unless you don't have any friends like i
suppose i'm sure there's a lot of people
like that
i think we're going to see more
especially when you start seeing a vowel
pop out
fabe will pop out halo infinite is going
to be a big time where you see consoles
and that's crazy this isn't even a time
where con like a big popular games
coming out like
uh like i'm sure that we're gonna see
another surge when halo comes out
so the the crazy part is like when you
brought up earlier when you were talking
about
whether or not that you know they were
intentionally released that stock i
think all they really did is instead of
releasing the stock like
throughout the month they released it
all at once you know what i'm saying
because i don't think that microsoft and
sony have like a huge difference in in
and in consoles right now
i think they're both struggling to get
as many as they possibly can
because a lot of people are trying to
say that the only reason they want mpds
is because microsoft just had more units
to sell
so it's just like i i don't i don't get
that because they're both always
sold out unless you go to like these
weird websites that
have one that you're kind of like should
i risk 500
for this for this pla xbox
no you're right i mean it's all about
it's all about who probably sends more
but
you know xbox is also using a lot of
those chips for xcloud as well so it's
not
exactly a one-to-one comparison but it's
it's not you know it's nice to see it's
nice to see
all three console manufacturers actually
top of their game nobody screwed up
because
you usually think about it usually a
generation one of them always screws up
you know last gen uh you know the xbox
the xbox screwed up
the gen before the wii u was a complete
disaster
uh ps3 basically almost destroyed
playstation like
it always does seem one of the console
manufacturers
somehow trips over their own feet and
place face plants
and for the first time in a long time
here you have it like all three seem to
be doing well everybody loves the switch
it's always sold out even though i won't
i won't get in my nintendo slander right
now you know
attic knows how i feel about nintendo
but you can't deny
that people love it and they're people
are constantly buying
nintendo software and nintendo hardware
uh you know playstation 5 is
the fastest selling console ever
in the first eight months of launch
right
it's it's selling better than the ps4 at
the same time and ps4 was 100
cheaper you know ps5 is doing this at
500
so you can even make the argument that
this is more impressive
because it's 100 more expensive it just
goes to show you
how um enamored consumers and customers
were with the ps4 gen
uh that they're like you know what we'll
upgrade to the ps5 for a hundred dollars
more
and and do it faster than we did for the
ps4 and then you have xbox coming off of
what was arguably a absolutely horrible
generation
the only thing that they really have in
their back pocket was game pass
right and that really took uh quite some
time to kind of lift off i mean now
you know who knows what it's going to
the numbers will be at the end of the
year but
there's talk maybe it'll be at like 30
million and
it definitely seemed like microsoft
turned it around
um so it's nice to see like all three
doing incredibly well
yeah because at the end of the day
competition's better for everyone you
know
i'm hoping that this steam deck thing
comes out and does well so it pushes
nintendo to try to
improve that because i don't think the
only thing they're gonna going to press
nintendo is something that's trying to
do what nintendo does and does it well
if this thing comes out and it's a
horrible flop and it doesn't sell too
many units
nintendo's just going to keep on moving
but if it comes out and it's mad
successful
and it's everywhere and it's and it's
taking some of its
it's user base like i could see nintendo
start like okay maybe we need to
to look into stuff a little bit more but
that market's just so hard to get to and
i don't know if they'll be able to get
to it i just don't
um but you know that's pretty much for
the show man i try to keep these show
i try shorts that that way you know i
don't keep uh rand's a busy man man he's
got it i'm not that busy i'm
i'm free today that's when you asked me
he's like hey can you be on him like
sure
you know nothing there's nothing going
on man he's
he's don't let him light you he's
playing halo infinite don't let him lie
i wish i wish i was playing halo
infinite i tell you man
i i you know i'm just waiting for an
email it was like hey
finale that'll never you know then
you'll see a reaction gift for me online
if that ever happened
i'd be like oh my god you know you
wouldn't know what to do if you're so
yeah pretty much or would that be that'd
be like me when i
when i uh when i got the email about
getting a series x early from xbox
i wanted to post something online but i
wasn't sure if i was allowed to so
you weren't going to risk that no i was
like i don't know that might break nda
so i'm not gonna say anything
yeah but you know i definitely
appreciate you coming on uh it's it's
been a good little uh
little good little episode uh you know
we'll
be back here next week definitely go to
uh go check out rand
i'm gonna put his uh his his twitter in
the in the description
he he posts a lot of good content man a
lot of good content
uh got two dollar scripts from everborn
saga what's good brothers what's good
everborn i was gonna hit you up to see
if you want to come
on but i was i was unaware if he was
busy or not and by the time
i was going to hit you up it was already
too late so
uh tell me definitely hit my dms if you
want to come on next week i think
i think i already know my guess next
week but where can where can people
catch you
um brand well besides you play halo
infinite it's
in secret i wish uh yeah i mean you
could check me out on youtube
uh youtube.comrandle419
uh you know with links there to twitter
and all those
excellent social media places which i
you know i barely use social media so
you can always follow me on twitter i
won't clog up your timeline like other
people
yeah thanks for talking about me talking
about me you doctor you know
you barely tweet is you don't tweet as
much i mean i mean you tweet about
about the same i think yeah i really
don't tweet a whole lot i don't really
maybe once or twice we have like the
same amount of tweets you have twenty
four thousand i have like twenty five
thousand
so yeah what's funny is uh iop
because they tweet all the articles from
the website they're starting to get up
there and uh
the amount but yeah i definitely
appreciate it for coming by man uh you
know definitely go out there check rand
check the xbox two this friday uh you
know it's
hopefully this friday unless uh
hopefully it depends unless jazz gets
you know it's fighting it's sliding door
you know sometimes friday sometimes
saturday you never know
yeah so definitely go check that out man
get that psychonauts
backstory man i'm sure he gonna have
them they'll probably talk about
mayonnaise and all kinds of
condoms i don't want to talk about any
of that stuff all right
but i i definitely appreciate every
coming by we're going in the podcast
we'll see you next week
but definitely show up too sunday at 1
p.m for the iron lords podcast
right now we only got one topic right
now uh they really
hopefully something will happen i know
it's it's tuesday
usually stuff gets announced like monday
and tuesday but
hopefully though we'll get something man
we'll wing it regardless that's what
we'll do we'll wing it regardless but
we'll